[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Need me to sit right here?
>> Yep, that's right.
So Ariana welcome to Stanford.
>> Thank you so much,
what a fabulous auditorium.
>> We handpicked them
specifically just for you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So you often quote a Persian poet
who encouraged us to live our lives as
though they were rigged in our favor.
Now as it is often easy to
proclaim the fact after success,
it appears as though you actually
embodied this mindset from an early age.
But not just you, your parents, too.
So, I was wondering if you could take
us back to Greece where it all began.
And share with the audience a story
as to how your parents met and
how they came to be in Greece.
>> Well, first of all Liv, thank you so
much for starting with my favorite quote,
which I carry with me
laminated in my wallet.
And which I keep bombarding my children
with, in fact my oldest daughter,
Christina is here, so
she's heard it many times.
It really did all start with my mother,
because we lived in a one bedroom
apartment in Athens, Greece.
And one day, I saw a picture in
the magazine of Cambridge University.
And I said to everybody who could listen,
I really want to go there.
And everybody said don't be
ridiculous you don't speak English.
We don't have any money and
it's really competitive to get into
Cambridge even if you're an English girl.
But my mother said,
let's see how you can get there, and
that involved going to the British
council and taking my GCS.
Which as you know since
you're an Oxford girl,
it's what you need to take as
the first step and borrowing Money.
And then one thing which I kind of love,
is that she said, one day,
I got us these cheap tickets and
we can go and see Cambridge.
It was just kind of an early
visualization trip.
We're not going to see
anybody at Cambridge.
We're just, we're going to see Cambridge
and kind of make it more real for
me that I could go there.
And to cut a long story
short I got an exhibition,
which is kind of a scholarship,
a version and a scholarship.
I remember getting the telegram
saying awarded exhibition and
I have to find out what
the hell was exhibition.
[LAUGH] And to Cambridge and
that definitely changed my life.
It was kind of the unexpected trajectory
that made a lot of other things possible.
Especially because I fell in love with
a Cambridge union, the Debating Society.
And I really, really put a lot of
my energy into learning to speak.
And whenever anybody says,
well I can't speak or
I'm terrified of speaking,
apparently public speaking is,
in terms of fears,
higher up than death by mutilation.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, so this is not good for
me right now, then.
Okay, good to know.
>> [LAUGH] So I started literally
by writing down every word.
I would be called in
sometimes after midnight.
And because I was so bad and
also had this heavy accent which was even-
>> Accents are good.
[LAUGH] Accents are good.
>> Well maybe now, maybe in America.
But you know perfectly well,
not in England.
Anyway, so [LAUGH]
>> You've
got to take whatever card you can play so
I'll take the British accent here.
>> So I spent an enormous
amount of time at the union.
In fact, I spent more time at
the union than I spent studying,
which is why you got a first at Oxford and
I only got a two one.
>> Okay, and that's why you're sitting
in that chair and I'm right here.
>> Well, you are 3,000 years younger so.
>> So on that point, in Thrive You,
one of your best selling books,
you talk about having this inner voice,
that sort of obnoxious neighbor.
And yet, from the outside,
you look as though you have
this remarkable self belief.
Because you not only went to Cambridge but
despite a glorious accent,
you decided to run for
president of Cambridge.
And became the first foreign lady or
foreign lady at all to become President.
That continued thereafter whereby
after your first successful book,
your next one was
rejected 36 times before.
And then even with the Huffington Post,
you launched it to a backdrop of critics.
So this perseverance appears to be
a common thread throughout your journey.
How much of that spun from
drive of being the underdog, or
was it a mindset that you
taught yourself over time?
>> Well, it was a mindset that
was very much something that
my mother kept talking about.
One of her favorite sayings was failure
is not the opposite of success.
It's a stepping stone to success.
But the obnoxious roommate,
that voice of doubt and
self-judgment, remains very loud.
And people don't write about it.
But I can tell you, I can still hear it.
I can still still hear, for example,
when I gave my first big speech at the,
what do they call?
Do they still call it a paper speech?
>> They do indeed, yeah,
traditions die hard.
>> Meaning that you actually are one of
the main speakers as opposed to somebody
they call on after the main speakers.
And I was speaking on
the same side as JK Galbraith
against William Buckley and
I remember every detail.
And the topic of
the speech was The Market,
meaning the flea market is a snare and
a delusion.
And I was sitting next to Galbraith and
while Buckley was speaking,
Galbraith leaned over to me and
said, can you stand up.
You have the right at the union to stand
up and every speaker has to give way for
the point you want to make.
So can you stand up, he said,
and interrupt him and make it.
And he mentioned some kind of
recondite econometric point,
which I stupidly stood up and
interrupted Buckley with.
And then he turned to me and
said, well madam,
I don't know what market you patronize and
brought the house down.
And I sat down feeling
completely humiliated,
which would have been neither here nor
there.
Except the obnoxious roommate, for
the next week, I'm not exaggerating.
Was replaying that incident
as though this was the end,
not just of my career, but my life.
And looking back, of course,
it is none of the above,
but that's what
the obnoxious roommate does.
And it kind of basically tears you apart,
and I've had so
many experiences like that,
where all my energy would be
absorbed in listening to that voice.
And that's why I've spent a lot
of of time in my life trying to
evict the obnoxious roommate from my head.
And I'm doing a pretty good job now but
it took many, many years.
And it changes your life when you
don't have to waste your energy
dealing with that voice but
you can actually go on with your life.
And recognize that sometimes thing
are not going to go well, and
sometimes you're not going to perform
at your best and that's part of life.
It's funny you say that because I read
somewhere that you appear to be in your
own person from a very young age.
Would you mind sharing the story
about your fifth birthday party?
>> [LAUGH] Yes I always love to read.
I love to lose myself in books.
And so from my fifth birthday party,
my mother had invited my best friends.
And I told them they had to go home
because they were interrupting my reading.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah well this is clearly a passion and
although you've written 15 books to date
now across a wide variety of topics.
It seems to be politics that's kind
of captured your attention the most.
What is it that drew you to the political
sphere, especially in the discussion and
commentary side?
>> So, it was politics and
as the Dean mentioned,
the Third World America book was
very much sort of my deep concern about
what was happening in the country.
And how we are not paying
sufficient attention, and
that remains a very deep concern of mine.
But, I now feel increasingly that
the thing we are most starved for
in our political lives as well as
the rest of our lives is wisdom.
And I feel that we're kind of drowning
in data and starved for wisdom.
And so my passion now is,
how can we connect
with that part of ourselves that
is the wisest part of ourselves?
And whether we are politicians or
business leaders or media leaders.
There are huge problems in front of us.
And if we don't connect to that part,
we are going to be operating and
making decisions from the surface.
And as a result missing the opportunity
to really come up with big solutions.
And I was fascinated by
how leaders that we admire throughout
history have done that in the past.
Like one of my favorite stories that I've
included in my new book, is about FDR.
In 1940, when there was all this
pressure on him to enter the war.
But the American public was completely
opposed to it, so he didn't literally,
he didn't know what to do, and what he
did would never have happened today.
He took ten days off and
went on a naval ship around the Caribbean.
And Eleanor would send him
letters saying things,
I'm so happy to think of you sleeping and
refueling.
And his aids afterwards have
written how he truly refueled and
in the process of refueling.
He came up with what was a political
masterpiece of a solution.
The land lease program that allow
the America to enter their war and
at the time when otherwise public opinion
would have been completely opposed to it.
And I feel we all need to do that.
And we need to validate people
who do that as opposed to judging
politicians who gone vacation or
who play golf.
Who do anything to refuel and
therefore ideally come up with
the solutions if they are really
at the heart of leadership.
>> It's interesting because some may say
that the reason that it doesn't happen
is because of this 24/7 media commentary.
And increasingly it's thought
in some circles that media is
increasingly shaping politics as
opposed to just reporting of it.
So, how do you think through and try and
control that with your curation and
editorial prowess?
So you mean it's our fault, right?
[LAUGH]
>> I was trying to be diplomatic.
Some they say.
Certainly not myself but some.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I think we first of all,
we are not going to avoid the 24/7
nature of media and the internet.
This is whether you,
even if you never go the Huffington Post,
or the New York Times site, or any site.
You have your Facebook and
Instagram and endless social media.
So that's going to be the nature
of our lives going forward.
So that's why it's even more imperative
that we learn to set our own boundaries.
And that we need to
stop giving in to FOMO,
the fear of missing out
>> We don't know if that is here totally.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because in the end what
we're missing out on is our life.
And that is something which will
require a major culture shift.
I mean we can do it individually and
a lot of people are doing it.
And ironically there is now more and
more technology that paradoxically
is helping us deal with technology.
But in the end, it will require
some support from the culture,
whether it's culture at school,
at college,
and the workplaces where we are and
our families.
So I feel that we are in the process
now of a major culture shift,
and we're in the middle
of this transition.
And like any other transition,
a lot of different types of
behavior are valued and
not exhibited, all at the same time.
And whether you're optimistic or
pessimistic depends on what you focus on.
>> So this Fourth Revolution
has been a big topic at Davos
amongst many of the world leaders.
And you ran for
governor of California once but
haven't returned to
politics directly yourself.
What caused you to run then and
why not since and
would you like to bring
about the 4th resolution?
>> [LAUGH] No, I have,
I would rather have five hour root canal.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There's
very few things that I can categorically
say but I would never run for office is
one of them which I'm sure Christina
my daughter will be happy to hear.
She was very opposed to my
running in the first place.
I would never run,
first of all because I feel
I can contribute more with what I'm doing.
And secondly, because politics at
the moment is completely poisoned and
I think that's one of the problems
that really we got to the point where
anybody who can do anything else is not
going to enter political life anymore.
So we would definitely need
to change the system so
that we can bring in
better people to run but
I am definitely not
going to be one of them.
Maybe you, maybe you decide to-
>> Well you'll certainly do without
me bumbling along and
making a mess of things.
Okay, so let's talk about the platform
from which you're currently able to
shape the view, the Huffington Post.
So you established this back in the day,
it was a revolutionary online platform,
mix or original content,
aggregation and blogging.
Yet you were at the time neither
part of the media establishment nor
a common man that the bloggers
represented nor a tech person.
So how did the idea come about and how
did you get it off the ground initially?
>> So the idea really came
about because I could see that
the conversation was moving online, and
I wanted to sort of Elevate
the online conversation,
because as you said, at the time,
bloggers were perceived as
people who couldn't get a job,
in their pajamas,
in their parent's basement.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I want to demonstrate that,
in fact, it could be different.
And so from the beginning,
my aspiration for Huff was,
remember we started with five people
out of my home in Los Angeles, but my-
>> In the basement, in their pajamas.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, not in the basement,
a rather nice office but [LAUGH] but
still, a tiny operation.
But the goal was to ultimately become
both a journalistic enterprise
of the kind that we did become,
we now have 850 reporters,
editors, engineers in 15 countries,
we won a Pulitzer.
So, to become a really substantive
journalistic enterprise, but
to also be a platform.
And that was just as
important from the beginning.
And on day one,
I had an amazing roster of bloggers.
I had emailed everybody I knew and
had said if there is anything on your mind
that you want to write about it, please
write about it on the Huffington Post.
And we're going to make it super easy for
you.
I know all of you could be writing for
The New York Times,
because I invited people
like Larry David and
Ellen DeGeneres and,
this is how long ago it was, so
many of them are dead now,
Walter Cronkite.
[LAUGH]
And basically,
we had this amazing first day
when a lot of these people,
everyone I just mentioned, was on the
first day of the Huffington Post blogging.
So suddenly, blogging was elevated
into something which you could do,
even though you could
actually write an op-ed
that would be accepted in
the Financial Times or The New York Times.
And the reason why they would do that
is because it was so much easier.
They would just write something and
we would post it and
they wouldn't be edited and
they wouldn't go back and forth,
asking them to make it shorter or
longer or whatever.
And, in fact,
we created a little concierge service
where people in LA could
literally dictate.
They could call us from
the phone from their cars and
we would take dictation and then send
it back to them to make any edits.
And I think Larry David, everything he
wrote, he would dictate from the set.
Ari Emanuel, who I remember, call me from
the golf course, and say I have this
idea about Mel Gibson, it's terrible
that Hollywood isn't going against him.
Remember when he made his
anti-semitic comments and
Hollywood was giving him a pass?
And, literally, Ari called me on a Sunday,
I took dictation, and
I sent it back to him,
he made a couple of changes,
we posted it and
it changed the climate in Hollywood.
Suddenly, Disney announced we're not going
to be doing his next movie, etc., etc.
So people began to see
the power of blogging and
the power of just expressing an opinion,
having it up immediately.
We had, from the beginning,
our comments were pre-moderated,
because I wanted to keep a civil
environment and avoid ad hominem attacks.
Because I felt like I was inviting
these people to come to my home and
express their views, and
I owed it to them that nobody was
going to suddenly start trashing them.
And we had very little money, we started
the Huffington Post with $2 million,
which I collected from my friends, and
my partner, Kenny Lerer, collected.
Actually, my first investors
were Laurie and Larry David and
when they got divorced they split
[LAUGH] the Huffington Post investment.
[LAUGH] And so
I remember paying my daughter's $5 each
to moderate comments,
they were in their early teens.
[LAUGH] And basically we used everything
we could to create from the beginning
a civil environment in which these
people would want to return.
And probably the breakthrough
moment was when,
who was the identity of
deep throat was revealed.
Do you remember that?
And Nora Ephron was in high demand,
everybody wanted her to tell her story.
What did she know, when did she know it,
because at the time she was,
because she had been
married to Carl Bernstein.
And so she calls me up and
she says, you know what,
I don't want to go to CNN and
get in makeup and I don't want to have to
bother with a New York Times op-ed,
I'm sending you my blog.
So the fact that Nora Ephron chose
this new platform to write something,
which was then everywhere,
made people realize that if it was
something that was newsworthy,
they could write in the Huffington Post,
then it would be everywhere anyway.
CNN and the New York Times and everybody
would be compelled to link to it,
because that was the only
way to get the story.
So that was when we really
kind of arrived in a way,
in terms of people coming to us to write,
and that has remained kind
of a big passion of mine.
Recruiting people,
interesting voices, in fact,
I want to invite all of you to write on
the Huffington Post, and I always make it
super easy by giving you my email address
so you can email it to me directly.
Now, we give people we trust passwords,
so you can post directly,
and then our editors ,front page and
social, and we translate the best,
so my email address is
arianna@huffingtonpost.com.
That's one of the good things when
you found a company you get a good
email address.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we are now up to
100,000 bloggers and
our goal is get to a million.
We're creating a lot of new
technology that will make
it easier to post and
to navigate the site, etc.
>> Good luck getting sleep after 500,
600 people email you their blogs.
But before we move on,
just on the point of the platform,
given that it was always
meant as this medium for
anyone to share their opinion and
voice pretty much unfiltered.
What led to the decision to share your
name with it, knowing that your personal
reputation will be associated with the
material posted on the website, and how,
if at all,
has that effected the curation process?
>> Well, I was always, like all in.
[LAUGH] There was never any
question of my separating
myself from the Huffington Post.
I have to say that my daughters begged
me not to call it the Huffington Post,
because they thought it was just going
to be an embarrassing failure and
they would not be able to
show their faces at school.
So I remember tearful
moments with Christina and
Isabella saying you can't call it the
Huffington Post, that's so embarrassing.
[LAUGH] And Isabella, my younger daughter,
announced that she will never blog,
and she hasn't.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so that, for me,
it was all like saying, I'm all in.
This is it and And curation though has
always been a very important part of
it from the beginning even though
the platform was open we have ground
rules like we will not
publish conspiracy theories.
Like if you think 9/11 was an inside job,
we're not going to publish
it on the Huffington Post.
We're not going to publish
cookie medical theory.
So we create a set of boundaries,
that you may disagree with
people who are writing but
it's not going to be
because they are insane.
[LAUGH]
>> It's always helpful,
a good boundary to have
in life in general.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, some of your recent books lament
the lack of surprise in the modern world
and yet, I know that this is a reason from
the fact that an online content is
filtered based on preexisting preferences.
So how would you think through the fact
that some platforms similar to
Huff Post are responsible for
creating this bubble effect and
kind of narrowing our preferences and
are you
thinking of ways to introduce serendipity
again online as browsing once did.
>> Well, right now actually,
what is happening is that
the majority of people don't receive that
information by going to a destination but
through social, even the heart of
the Post, which is probably the last
big destination site, and
that's now the majority of
our traffic through social Through people
posting something that they've read and
happened to post on Facebook,
or tagging their friends.
This is kind of a revolution
in how we create a site.
I tried to convince friends of mine,
for example, who.
I started a new business and
I invested a lot of money on the website.
How useless that is.
[LAUGH]
I actually say to them
that if I was launching the Huffington
Post today there would be no website
because it's all social.
And I think one of the reasons
why we succeeded at remaining at
the forefront of this business is
because we changed our strategy.
So three years ago,
because I woke up after eight hours
sleep feeling completely recharged,
I could see the iceberg that was
about to hit the Titanic And
the iceberg was that people were not
going to be coming to the Huffington Post
directly in the large numbers they were
coming to the Huffington Post directly.
We had, our operation was being
driven very much around our Splashes.
We launched the idea of the Splash early
on in the life of the Huffington Post,
which was again very radical and
controversial at the time because the idea
was that you needed to put as many stories
as possible at the top, kind of above
the fall, to drive traffic to them.
And we said, no.
We are going to announce what we consider
is the most important story of the moment.
We may change it ten times in
the course of the day, but
it created a sense of drama.
It made people keep wanting to come
back to see what's the big story now.
And we hired editors
who really knew how to
create amazing headlines that were
a little playful and not conventional
One of my favorites was when
Dominique Strauss-Kahn was arrested.
Our headline was OMG, IMF.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
so the point, though,
was as things change
>> We decided
to stop prioritizing
our other front pages.
We still prioritize the front page because
we're still getting enough traffic to it.
But we stop prioritizing the splashes
of what by then we had 70 sections
at the Huffington Post covering everything
from, Colleges to wellness, to business.
And editors would spend a lot of time
creating beautiful splashes which would be
seen by fewer and fewer people,
so we, made different teams
that instead worked on how
to make content be social.
And be viral.
But here's another thing we discovered.
Normally we think of content
going viral as being
cats on skateboards or cute animals, and
we discovered that the content that goes
most viral is content around solutions.
Things that people want to share
>> Positive stories, yeah.
>> And so we have now focused our
coverage in three main areas,
you know, the first is obviously news and
politics, where we take our own,
you know, I would consider our job
to take stands We don't consider it
our jobs simply to blindly kind
of just write what's happening,
because we feel you can
get that anywhere now.
Why come to the Huffington Post
if you just want to know who won
the Wisconsin race?
First of all, you'd have gotten
it from your Twitter feed.
So for us, I mean, just one of the most
controversial thing we did that
everyday that passes,
I consider one of our best decisions, was
covering, at the beginning,
Donald Trump in the entertainment section.
[LAUGH]
And then on the day that he announced
that his proposal to ban 1.6 million,
billion Muslims from this
country to start covering him
under a clear present danger
who then editor's note appended
Underneath each story were his name
appears that says, we would like to remind
our readers that Donald Trump regularly
advocates balance at his lies.
And is a birth.
Which people forget.
People forget that his still believes
Obama was not born in this country.
Wants to ban at one point
six billion Muslims,
a serial liar, misogynist and xenophobe.
So-
>> Quite subtle.
>> It's very subtle.
[LAUGHTER] So basically we have
no opinion on Donald Trump.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> And really, I think the key here
was that in a way, you think how can
you cover both entertainment then a clear
and present danger, king Kim Jong Un,
you know, somebody who is
both a buffoon and a danger.
The two things are not contradictory, and
the two of them really exemplify that
fact, so that's one bucket
The other bucket is solutions and
why we have a dedicated
section called What's Working
who brought in a great journalist from
The Guardian Jo Confino to run it.
And in every area whether it's business,
the environment, workplaces,
we focus on what is working.
What are the solutions that are working
and this is the content that goes more
viral than anything, it's absolutely
amazing and the third market is Wellness.
>> Just on that point again, a lot of the,
even through your Facebook feed and
so forth, comes again from
your Preconceived tendencies.
So when certain articles pop up,
for example, someone searches on
the immigration crisis, would it not be a
case of having on one side, the story, but
then on the other,
something like and by the way,
here are the great immigrants that build
America like Steve Jobs was Syrian?
And so forth and having them side
by side such that it's almost
put in front of every reader,
regardless of what they search for.
>> Well absolutely we would be
covering the basics of the story.
This is not kind of
an alternative to that.
But so often media cover the crisis, the
problem, without also covering the fact
that There are solutions to most problems
that are actually happening somewhere.
But they are just not scaled enough.
So, I know you do a lot of work here.
But how do you scale something good?
So we feel that by putting
the spotlight on why this is working,
we can help them scale.
We talk about copycat crimes,
how about copycat solutions?
So I think that for us, the larger
point here is reimagining journalism.
So that in journalism schools,
right now you are taught
that if it bleeds, it leads.
And of course if anybody's unfortunate
enough to watch local new,
you would've thought that the only things
going on the communities are burglaries,
rapes, murders, and
this is just the choice of the outlet.
They think that's the way to drive people
to their broadcast, but I think the fact
that now most people receive their news
through social is changing the dynamic.
>> So, on the topic of solutions,
a lot of your current book is around
kind of helping us as individuals
become better at what we do.
Now what many may not know given your long
string of successes is the continuous
stream of personal hurdles that
went on in the background, right?
You very unfortunately had complications
with your first pregnancy,
you had a breast cancer scare, I believe.
You had a public divorce,
within the family, certain issues
around substance abuse and so forth.
And yet you continue to go on and
be successful.
To what extent was work a distraction
to help get through these moments?
And why was it that it took a literal bump
to your head to get you to kind of wake
up and reevaluate, and now help us to
avoid that situation in the future?
Sorry for the question.
>> No, that's great.
I think that work was never a distraction
because I always kind of loved my work.
I think what lead to my
collapse in 2007 and
my breaking my cheekbone on the way down,
was that I had completely
bought into the collective
delusion that burnout was
the way to achieve things.
That yes, I know I'm exhausted and
I know I'm kind of sleep walking
through my life but hey,
I'm building the Huffington Post.
And I had the delusion that so
many entrepreneurs have.
That nothing could be done except by me.
[LAUGH] And therefore,
I had to be up all the time and
driving this third baby that I
considered the Huffington Post
while my first baby, Christina,
was on college tour with me and
she had asked rightly that I should not be
on my Blackberry while we were together.
Remember, that's 2007, so
just a Blackberry time.
And when she would go to sleep,
I would start working and
to cut a long story short,
I ended up back at home collapsing.
But in a way I feel very, very grateful.
Speaking going back to Roomie and
living life as if everything
is rigged in your favor.
I honestly believed I
would either be dead or
have had a heart attack if
I had continued that way.
Because these things become cumulative,
so the price you pay,
it's not obvious right away.
Things seem to be working
until they stop working.
And the great thing about
last year was that it was
the year when executive after
executive collapsed, and
either died or
ended up with a heart attack.
Most recently the CEO of United Airlines.
And if you read his schedule before
his collapse, you can see why.
He's back at work now but
he ended up with a major heart attack.
The CEO of BMW collapsed
during a press conference.
The head of MMA at JP Morgan,
Jimmy Lee, died on his treadmill.
And I mean, I could go on and
on and what is interesting
is that we've kind of convinced
the world that exercise and
nutrition are important,
whether we do it or not,
we kind of recognize they're important.
But the third leg of the stool is sleep.
And you have people who
are literally put the alarm on and
they wake up exhausted,
then drag themselves to the gym.
Which now every sleep scientist, and you
have some of the best here at Stanford,
will tell you it's just a terrible mistake
for your health and for your weight.
If all you care about is your weight,
sleep in.
Don't wake up sleep deprived and go the
gym, because your body is going to crave
carbs and sugars in order to be
able to function during the day.
>> It is somewhat ironic
that in the Valley,
we have sheer panic attacks when our
iPhone depletes in energy down to like 7%.
But the fact that we're charging and
running around at 2% doesn't
seem to affect us at all.
>> That is such a great point in fact,
if you think of it,
we do take better care of our
smartphones then we take of ourselves.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because as you said I actually begin to
panic at about 13%, is yours 7?
Mine barely gets turned on so I'm okay.
>> I normally travel with about three
portable chargers just in case.
And yet, if they had asked me the day
I collapsed, Ariana, how are you?
I would have said fine.
Because exhaustion had
become the new normal.
And do you know now,
that if you go on Google,
at least when I last checked a week ago,
and you type out why am I,
the most common auto-complete
is why am I so tired?
And the second most common
auto-complete is why am I always tired?
>> So, so
I like your mantra of encouraging
us all to sleep our way to the top.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's not my words, credit goes to you.
Obviously, it's all good and well, kind
of raising awareness among the rank and
file, but the challenge is
the environment in which we operate.
So to what extent to your point around
all these CEOs kind of waking up and
literally smelling the coffee,
do you think that there should be an
equivalent of the giving pledge for sleep?
Whereby you kind of shame everyone into
getting rid of that social stigma,
writing on paper their commitment
to adopt the third metric,
embody a work environment
which rewards people for
coming in rested, auto-deletes
emails when they're on holiday.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Gives you taxis to get home at night
when you're sleep deprived and-
>> What are you doing when you graduate?
>> Working on this.
>> [LAUGH] These are brilliant ideas.
I love the equivalent of the giving
pledge, let's talk about that afterwards.
I think this is a really
fantastic idea because really,
we are talking about the need for
a culture shift, and there are pioneers,
who are leading the way, and
removing some of the stigma.
When, for example, Satya Nadella,
when he became the CEO of Microsoft,
told Business Insider that he sleeps for
eight hours, and
could not be an effective CEO if he did
not, that was pretty revolutionary.
Because in the past, and
when I say in the past,
I mean a year ago, before he said it,
even if a CEO was sleeping eight hours,
he would never admit it.
Because the whole idea was the Jon Bon
Jovi song that I'll sleep when I'm dead,
or you lose you snooze,
you snooze you lose.
Or congratulating people for
working 24/7, which now sleep scientists
will tell you is the cognitive
equivalent of coming to work drunk but
that has been the prevalent culture.
And now, I mean, actually, last week,
[COUGH] too late to include it
in the book, was a real tipping point.
And that was a McKinsey
study that they extracted
part of the Harvard Business Review, I
don't know why they didn't do it for you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And [COUGH].
>> We were busy sleeping.
>> A mistake, a clear mistake,
which the title first of all,
when you saw the title, you would
have thought it was from The Onion.
The title was The Proven Link Between
Effective Leadership and Sleep.
And it was co-written By the Mackenzie
Chief Global Learning Officer and
a woman who was identified as
Mackenzie's sleep specialist.
The idea that Mackenzie has
a sleep specialist, to teach you
not how to do without sleep, but
to teach you the importance of sleep.
Shows that we are in
an amazing site guys moment.
And once I stop kind of pinching myself,
I celebrated the part of this had happen
and reach out of course to the people who
wrote it to have them write about it on
having them first, which they're doing.
And incidentally, the sleep specialist
has now been hired by Facebook
to give these workshops at Facebook.
So this is all an amazing new phenomenon
and what I love about this piece,
which I highly recommend,
is that they walk you through what
happens to the prefrontal cortex.
Which is where the leadership functions,
that's what it called the executive
functioning is housed.
And how incredibly degraded they
are when they are sleep deprived.
And then I was co-hosting
Squawk Box on Tuesday
and I asked Mark Marburg one of the good
things about co-hosting and he said you
can invite people that you want to bring
these messages to the financial community.
And I invited Mark Bertolini,
the CEO of Aetna
because I wanted him to talk about the new
initiative that he started at Aetna.
And the third largest
health insurance company,
which is he asked his employees to
track their sleep with the Fitbit and
anyone who gets at lease seven hours
a night gets $25 for each night.
And that's kind of again
an amazing statement,
by this sea of health insurance company.
And then he has Duke tracking the results.
And they are finding a 7%
reduction in healthcare costs
in all the wellness programs they have.
And a 62-minute a week
improvement in productivity.
So it really helps dispel
all these illusions that
in order to be productive you
have to cut down on sleeps.
>> So I hope all my professors
are listening because I often email them
saying terribly sorry it's late,
I overslept, and they're like Leigh,
the class is at 3:30, and
I was like I was having a nap, you know?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now I can just forward them and
tell them I was decreasing my study.
>> You're increasing your performance.
>> Exactly, exactly.
>> Is that this afternoon?
>> No.
>> I have a conversation here at Stanford,
if you have woken up from your nap,
you going to come.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I set the alarms.
>> With Ingrid Iguodala,
the MVP from the Golden State Warriors,
and the conversation's being
introduced by Emmanuel Mignot,
Head of your Stanford Sleep Center.
>> And he's going to talk about
how sleep changed his game.
And he has tracked it,
he has all the data.
And he in fact, Instagrammed himself
holding his MVP while sleeping.
Because he feels he only got that because.
His game is so dramatically improved
when he started getting enough sleep.
And I love pointing to athletes,
because all they care about winning.
So, those in business school
who only care about winning.
I hope there's nobody here like that, but
let's say, that's all you care about,
succeeding, winning.
>> And lose weight.
>> Getting to the top.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> Sleep is a performance
enhancement tool.
>> Yeah.
Well clearly I've been dozing a bit on
stage because we haven't
got that many minutes left,
but we'll turn to the audience for
some questions, and
they'll be two microphones roaming
with Kara at the back there to start.
>> Great,
we'll start with a question from Twitter
>> What do you think is the future for
online content creation?
>> Well, the future is incredibly bright.
I think what's happening now is
that we are all content creators,
it's not just publishers who
are content creators, anybody can
be a content creator whether
you're a student and
entrepreneur or a brand.
In fact brands increasingly now,
have entire departments that
are about content creation and
we're talking earlier backstage
about native advertising.
For us of their having their posts,
native advertising and
it has become a major
source of monetization.
And what we have finding is that
we have a separate department,
separate from editorial.
But informed by the same beliefs.
And standards that creates contents for
brands.
We, for example,
made a very profitable idea
with Sleep Number, which is a mattress
company with embedded technology.
And we have a dedicated section,
it is transparently labeled
as a sponsored section.
But again, as we're discussing backstage,
that doesn't stop people from
wanting to consume the content,
provided the content is good,
credible, and well produced.
>> Hi, Arianna.
Thanks so much for joining us.
There is an article out today in
the New York Times playing on the growing
wealth disparity in this country
that also says that the richest
people in the United States far
outlive the poorest people.
This is not necessarily new but
that gap is widening.
Part of the reason for this is stress and
unhealthy living habits.
And so I wonder what you're doing as
you're promoting this message of wellness,
including sleep, that there are a lot
of people who can't partake in, and
that's not accessible to them.
So how do we make sure that we're
not just continuing to grow
this divide where those of us in this room
get to be healthy and happy and wealthy.
And there are a lot of people who
don't experience those benefits.
>> That's a great question and, in fact,
I tried to cover this in the book.
And two weeks ago,
we had a clinic in Harlem.
We took over a church.
And invited people from
the community to come in.
And we had a group of doctors, Dr.
Oz actually filmed it and it was an entire
hour on his show last week, to talk about
the health and their sleep specifically.
And what is fascinating is that
the delusions that we talked about,
that permeated the top,
have actually permeated also
the bottom socio-economic class and
unfortunately with even worse
information being given to them.
I talked to multiple people.
Most of them significantly overweight and
a lot of them suffering from diabetes.
And we're talking about
people in their 30s and 40s.
And most of them told me the same story.
I have two jobs, I have three jobs,
I sleep for four hours a night.
And I really blame myself
everyday because I'm exhausted.
And they thought that if they
were a Wall Street high flyer,
then wouldn't be exhausted.
So that's how they had
interpreted our delusion.
And when
you sort of ask more question, what would
happen, let me just give you a one story.
This was a woman in her early 30s
was a pastry chef and a babysitter.
And she said I would come
home after my jobs and
that was my time to watch my shows.
So that was her reward and
what she didn't realize is
that she was short changing herself of the
one thing that was freely available and
that she desperately needed,
and that was sleep.
So sometimes, she said,
I would watch for four hours and
then fall asleep with the tv.
Then the tv would wake her up and
then she said I would be so tired.
But yet I couldn't go back to sleep so I
would go and have something sweet to eat.
So the vicious cycle was perpetuated.
So there's a lot that needs to be done.
You know, we need to raise minimum wage,
we need to deal with the dangers of
technology taking away so many jobs for
that people being retrained,
there is a lot we can do.
Sleep alone is not going to
solve all of these problems.
But here is something which is freely
available that would dramatically change
the health equation and the resilience
of people who are struggling.
And so that's definitely part of
the campaign that we are running now
which is focusing on these groups and
on colleges.
And the reason we
are focusing on colleges,
we're doing sleep fairs in 100 colleges.
It's because this is the generation,
it's your generation that's
going to change the culture.
And so, in this league first, we are,
as well as giving a lot of free things
that make sleep easier, including pillows,
let's say sleeping our way to the top.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And we also are offering,
which are available at
Stanford all this week,
free Uber rides at night by Toyota.
All you have to do is
put the promo code in,
if you're a Stanford student
it's ToyotaSafetySU.
And Toyota is offering this because
they're partnered with Uber and
the Huffington Post in underlining
the dangers of drowsy driving.
And because what's happened,
again part of the culture with
drunk driving,
we've kind of won the battle.
The numbers are going significantly down
because people are much more reluctant
to get behind the wheel
when they are drunk.
But not when they are drowsy,
the numbers are going up.
So it was 1.2 million crashes
last year and 8,000 deaths.
So we have a PSA about it,
Travis Kalanik and I on tomorrow.
We are doing ride alongs with Uber
drivers, so you can actually request us
you can, the promo code is-
>> You've gotta do selfies and
take videos while that's happening.
>> Yeah, right, having it, and
then we take you where you want to go,
we don't kidnap you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But in this process, you have Travis me
talk to you about not driving while drowsy
and any other of your bad sleep habits And
we give you a big fabulous bag
with a lot of good things in it.
>> I think it's a very
interesting question though,
because one is almost
driven by necessity and
the other is almost like a privileged
choice that we end up in.
But suddenly we've run
out of time Arianna.
But I just want to mention a story as
we close to kind of just share with
the audience how from dark places
come great things like Ariana.
We didn't touch it on the beginning, but
the story is to how your parents met.
And it was at a hospital in Greece,
where I believe your
father was recovering from
the Nazi concentration camp where
he'd been taken as he was
a journalist back in the day.
And at the same time her mother
was fleeing from Russia and
in there recovering from TB thinking that
she'd never be able to get pregnant.
So just to show, from despair come
wonderful things like Arianna.
She's been delightful, so please join me
in thanking her for being with us today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]